[Música]
economía en directo América de Francia
24 me acompaña en esta mesa de trabajo
en la matinal Jorge Hurtado Jorge Buen
día buena mañana de lunes vamos a
comenzar hablando de Italia porque luego
las elecciones Cuáles serán Entonces los
retos de un momento al gobierno de
Georgia meloni que está a punto de
convertirse en la primera ministra de
ese país Raúl crisis energética y
privatizaciones sin duda Esos son los
principales retos que va a tener el
gobierno allí y tal vez importó en 2021
el 90% de su suministros de gas el 40%
de ellos desde Rusia y tiene actualmente
las reservas de gas por encima del 80%.
el nuevo gobierno debe seguir la línea
iniciada por el gabinete de Mario draghi
y buscar más fuentes alternativas para
las compras de gas pero también decidir
de Dónde sacar esos recursos para
aliviar a la familia hacia las empresas
con mayores problemas económicos sobre
todo con el tema de la inflación Italia
fue el país más beneficiado por el plan
de reducción o de recuperación europeo
con un paquete de unos 200 mil millones
de euros para financiar proyectos y
estimular el crecimiento económico pero
para obtener esos fondos Roma debe
implementar una serie de complejas
reformas previamente negociadas con
Mario drague pero melón y este que se
convertiría en la primera ministra mujer
en ese país dijo en campaña electoral
que quiere volver a negociar con la
comisión europea las condiciones para
recibir estos fondos el gobierno también
deberá afrontar la privatización de la
aerolínea Ita que se encuentra en
proceso de liquidación y del banco a ver
si me corregir el italiano Raúl del
banco del pachi de Siena recapitalizado
en 2017 por sus problemas financieros
dice bien lo hiciste perfecto Jorge
vamos a hablar de la guerra en Ucrania
Jorge porque está provocando una
desaceleración económica más de lo
prevista hace ya algunos meses bueno
Esto lo dice la organización para la
cooperación y el desarrollo económico
ocde Pese a que este año el aumento el
mundo crecerá un 3% ahora se prevé que
se reduzca al 2,2% en 2023 eso significa
el próximo año se perderían unos 2,8
billones de dólares una caída del 2% el
término de poder adquisitivo el
organismo se mostró pesimista sobre las
perspectivas de Europa la economía más
expuesta directamente a las
consecuencias de la guerra de Rusia en
Ucrania muchos países europeos caerán en
recesión en 2023 y hay problemas de
abastecimiento de gas los próximos meses
dice este informe el informe también
señala que Argentina Brasil y México y
Sudáfrica al estar bastante expuestos a
los ciclos de la economía mundial y a la
demanda de los países ricos van a sufrir
Una severa ralentización el año próximo
la ocde afirmó que son necesarias nuevas
subidas de tipos de interés para luchar
contra la inflación y pronóstico que los
tipos oficiales de la mayoría de los
países o de los bancos centrales del
mundo van a superar el 4% el próximo año
y eso es lo que tienen los mercados
nerviosos porque al subir los tipos de
interés que aumenta el riesgo de una
recesión económica global cambiamos
ahora de información Jorge porque este
lunes la revista esterlina registró una
base histórica frente al Dólar esto por
los temores de recesión que hablábamos
anteriormente en Reino Unido luego de
que el nuevo ministro de finanzas casawi
quarting presentará un polémico plan de
reducción de impuestos los detalles y
los tiene nuestra corresponsal allí
Luisa Pulido
entonces del Mini presupuesto presentado
por el gobierno el viernes que incluye
el recorte de impuestos más grande en
los últimos 50 años ha generado
nerviosismo en los mercados tanto así
que la otrora Poderosa Libra esterlina
ha caído a su nivel más bajo también en
los últimos 50 años en comparación con
el dólar el anuncio de este paquete
financiero que tenía que hacer el
gobierno fue suspendido por la muerte de
la reina Isabel II y también por el
período de duelo nacional pero lo cierto
Es que este está generando un gran
efecto económico mucho temor por el
nivel de endeudamiento en el que está
incurriendo el gobierno británico la
preocupación ahora además de la crisis
en el costo de vida sumada a la
inflación que está disparada es que los
bienes importados que están cotizados en
dólares como el petróleo y el gas el
precio de estos vaya a aumentar y así
impacto directo en los hogares
británicos por ello el llamado a esta
hora de varios sectores al gobierno es
que tome medidas urgentes para
equilibrar el precio de la libra
esterlina Jorge cambiamos información
nos venimos a nuestro continente
precisamente a Colombia y Venezuela
porque está a punto de darse esta
reapertura del paso fronterizo entre
ambas naciones Cuáles son las
posibilidades económicas no todos los
comerciantes la expectativa de lo que va
a ser este intercambio también me gustan
los números vamos con los números en
2006 el intercambio comercial entre
Colombia y Venezuela sumaba casi dos mil
millones de dólares una cifra que se
disparó en 2008 a los 5 mil millones de
dólares pero que tras siete años del
flujo comercial interrumpido ahora no
superan ni los 300 millones de dólares y
la meta de la nueva relación comercial
según han dicho los funcionarios este
año la cifra podría llegar a los mil
millones de dólares los principales
beneficios o beneficiados con la
reapertura de de estas fronteras son los
comerciantes de ambos lados de la de
2.200 kilómetros algunos compradores de
alimentos otros productores de servicios
inclusive de limpieza proveedores de
materiales de construcción y cientos de
pequeños negocios sobre todo en
Venezuela que ahora incluso tendrían la
posibilidad de exportar sus productos al
exterior desde agosto de 2015 cuando los
cruces fronterizos cerraron por la
escalada de tensiones políticas décadas
de intercambio comercial se convirtieron
en una economía informal o en un mercado
negro Pese a que la economía venezolana
cayó un 80% en una década en los últimos
dos años se ha registrado un repunte del
consumo ahí también de la producción y
de las importaciones esto Gracias a la
dolarización y a la rebaja de algunos
controles estatales con esta
reactivación se espera que renazca
también el turismo entre ambas naciones
hoy saldría el primer avión de la
aerolínea turpial y el 4 de octubre
saldría también el primer vuelo
comercial desde Colombia con la
aerolínea wingo también se espera que se
termine el tránsito ilegal que la
expansión de bandas criminales y actos
delictivos en esa frontera la reapertura
representa para Colombia una oportunidad
de recuperar a un importante Aliado
comercial sobre todo ahora en un
contexto de aumento de precios de los
alimentos y los combustibles por la
guerra en Ucrania el nuevo embajador de
Colombia en Venezuela informó de la
llegada del primer buque con
fertilizantes desde ese país y ahí está
Jorge atrás usted tiene imagen imágenes
en vivo de este puente Simón Bolívar
donde Entonces a las 9 de la mañana hora
de Colombia y desde Venezuela va a tener
lugar esta reapertura que por supuesto
vamos a llevarle a todos ustedes en
directo Ahí está en nuestras enviadas
especiales en Cúcuta del lado colombiano
Daniela Blandón y el lado venezolano en
el estado táchira herminia Fernández
Gracias Jorge por toda la información
económica más adelante por supuesto más
economía nosotros pasamos a saludar a
Luis Méndez Zurich que tiene toda la
actualidad deportiva
[Música]